2022 peut-être sera l'année de sortie de
l'épidémie peut-être peut-être est-ce le
dernier variant peut-être est-ce la
dernière vague le gouvernement semble
être optimiste en ce début d'année en
prévoyant une éventuelle sortie de crise
en 2022 mais est-ce réaliste
[Musique]
tout d'abord en faisons un point d'étape
aujourd'hui santé publique france risque
d'annoncer pas loin de 300 milles
contamination sur 24 heures avec un taux
de reproduction effectifs soit le nombre
de personnes infectées par un seul
individu à plus de 6 pour omicron contre
5 pour le variant delta aps
le président de la république est bien
conscient que la cinquième vague s'est
dit les semaines à venir seront
difficiles nous le savons tous le virus
circule et circulera de plus en plus
emmanuel macron s'est montré optimiste
comment montrer en introduction de cette
vidéo alors que nous entrons dans la
deuxième année de la pandémie il se
pourrait qu'il ait raison tout d'abord
parce que le variant omicron semble être
moins dangereux
donc c'est un variant qui est plus
bénins plus contagieux donc on se
rapproche de quelque chose qui pourrait
s'appeler un rhume en plus de provoquer
des formes moins grave que les variants
précédent cette étude publiée dans ce
land set en prenant l'exemple de
l'afrique du sud démontre que la
proportion de cas admis était plus
faible est moins grave
donc si la dangerosité des variants est
moins importante c'est signifier aussi
que les besoins pour les patients
hospitalisés seront moindres et les
durées d'hospitalisation plus courte de
la même manière une projection de
l'institut pasteur se montre tout aussi
positive pour l'instant les données sur
la sévérité de mikron sont relativement
encourageante il ya une publication de
ce week end qui confirme que le rayo
licorne qui aujourd'hui celui qui est en
train de largement dominer au nord dé
beaucoup plus transmissible ça c'est
démontrer mais en contrepartie ils
semblent donner beaucoup plus de formes
asymptomatiques henrique casalino est
infectiologues et chef du département
des urgences à l'hôpital bichat à paris
pour lui la moindre sévérité du variant
est un facteur rassurant avec une
précision mais aussi il y à une donnée
qui est essentiel c'est que dans toutes
ses études l'élément déterminant de la
réduction de la gale c'est le fait
d'avoir été vacciné
d'ailleurs les chiffres le montrent le
taux de vaccination des français n'a
cessé d'augmenter et l'élan des plus
élevés au monde d'après ces chiffres
délivrés par le ministère de la santé
91% des français de plus de 18 ans sont
entièrement vacciner et plus de 24
millions de dose de rappel ont été
administrées au 1er janvier
dans ce cadre le taux de vaccination est
une donnée importante
comme l'expliquent une étude publiée par
l'agencé sanitaire britannique trois
doses de vaccin sont efficaces à 88%
contre les hospitalisations liées à
omicron comparé à une personne pas du
tout vacciner
ce variant omicron nous permettra-t-il
d'atteindre l'immunité collective qu'on
espère depuis deux ans olivier ferrand
ça plus la vaccination c'est une
possibilité c'est pourquoi j'ai dit que
c'était peut-être peut-être comme toi
tout est peut-être la dernière des
vagues l'immunité collective est un
objectif que nous attendons depuis le
début de l'épidémie soit le fait que la
population puisse se défendre face au
virus en produisant des anticorps en
passant par la vaccination ou en
attrapant le virus surtout que dès lors
que l'on aura été infectée par omicron
tous les anticorps que nous produisons
protège également des autres variant
auquel on a déjà été confrontée comme
l'expliquent henrique cassagne ça un
gearing réponse immunitaire qui permet
de nous protéger les autres parions que
nous allons connu jusqu'à maintenant ça
voudrait dire que si le virus circule
beaucoup effectivement on pourrait avoir
un niveau de protection collectif
[Musique]
autre facteur qui pousse les
professionnels à l'optimisme pour une
éventuelle sortie de crise cette année
ce sont les médicaments contre le colis
plusieurs traitements sont en cours de
recherche ou en attente de validation
comme le maule l'upi ravir de merck ou
encore le taxent le vide de pfizer ces
pilules ne préviennent pas la
contamination mais permettent de réduire
les cas graves et les hospitalisations
dans un avis datant du 16 décembre 2021
le conseil scientifique indiqué le
médicament par voie orale pacs loving
devrait être efficace car dirigée contre
la protéase du virus qui est peu modifié
mais ce produit ne sera disponible en
quantité qu'à partir de mi-février 2022
ces médicaments pourraient jouer un rôle
de complément aux vaccins dans la lutte
contre le collier l'arsenal
thérapeutique que s'élargit on ne se bat
pas contre le virus maintenant avec une
seule arme qui était à l'époque le
confinement le se battre contre le virus
avait plusieurs jouit ce qui a été
démontré c'est qu'il faut utiliser ces
outils de façon synergique et cohérente
c'est de la médecine du bon sens on
protège les plus fragiles et voilà à
quoi sert le vaccin la vaccination
massive et cette stratégie du tout
vaccinal est une mauvaise stratégie
d'ailleurs israël vient de revenir en
dix ans la quatrième dose elle va être
réservé à des gens qui sont fragiles
c'est ce qu'on aurait dû faire depuis le
début alors il ya eu la réponse
politique médiatico politique de sortie
de crise en ont dix ans on a une arme on
sait le vaccin on va vacciner tout le
monde mais maintenant il faut revenir à
de la région
reste une question quand on pourrait se
terminer l'épidémie qu'ovide sur le long
terme il faudrait attendre qu'elle passe
par une phase pandémique qui est la
suite logique de toute épidémie une
endémie revient à parler du virus de la
grippe par exemple dont la présence est
habituel avec un taux d'incidence stable
je n'ai point de vue scientifique c'est
possible il ya des virus qui
apparaissent et qui disparaissent
regardez le hezbollah en afrique lors sa
le sascoc la première génération celui
qui avait démarré aussi en asie et qui
avait touché le
moyen-orient est quelque part eu donc
c'est possible pour l'heure et selon l'
oms il faudrait s'attendre à
l'apparition de nouveaux variants
[Musique]
nous avons quelques éléments qui sont
plutôt on le change de quelque chose de
rassurant mais restons vigilants
je comprends qu'elle n'était rien de
nous faire baisser les bras
[Musique]